the Department of Justice is taking
groundbreaking action to crack down on
hundreds of millions of scam robo calls
we hate those things
it's filing for a temporary restraining
orders against us telecom carriers
allegedly facilitating those fraudulent
calls now most of them originate in
India and older Americans are losing
millions of dollars a year today the
Senate will hold a hearing to look into
what it called the number one scam in
America Social Security fraud our
consumer investigative correspondent
that's Anna Werner spoke to one witness
all set to testify unfortunately Anna a
lot of people can relate to this good
morning to you good morning yeah in the
past three months the Social Security
Administration says it's gotten more
than a hundred and fifteen thousand
complaints about the Social Security
scam now some people likely never lost
money but this Utah woman and her
husband lost more than most Americans
make in a year
it truly is embarrassing I'm embarrassed
I'm really embarrassed Michelle Anderson
and her husband Kyle a Utah State
Representative say they know many people
won't be able to believe they became
victims of the Social Security scam but
they say the fact they did means others
need a warning maybe it happened to us
so that we could help others the scam
started in December when Michelle says
she got calls like this one here social
has been found some suspicious for
committing fraudulent activities
claiming her social security number had
been compromised and had been used to
set up multiple bank accounts associated
with a drug cartel she says a man
claiming to be a DEA investigator then
said her family was in danger he
continued to talk to me about the danger
that my family was in if I didn't
cooperate that these people were very
dangerous that they were watching me
that I needed to do what I was told and
not tell anyone not only that she says
he told her she needed to transfer all
the money in the family's bank accounts
to an offshore account that would be
safe before the fraudulent accounts were
seized or she would lose all of their
money to prove it he sent her this what
he said was a warrant for her arrest for
drug trafficking and money
laundry that would be used if she didn't
show full cooperation so I drove to the
credit union and I transferred all of
her money into our checking account we
had CDs I I cast them in I paid the
penalties all told after a week's time
she wired $150,000 to the crooks it was
only after the scammer asked her to take
out a mortgage on their home that the
light finally daunt and she told her
husband something awful had happened and
she said I have I have given away every
penny that we have
I felt like throwing up you know I just
I mean I just felt this this gut punch
and I felt sick I was asked by someone
how could you be so stupid
but at the time that I was going through
it it was very real
that's our population ages that the
matter is only going to get worse
seniors have lost nearly 38 million
dollars to the scam says senator Susan
Collins often times our seniors are
embarrassed when they realized that
they've been ripped off and they're too
ashamed to admit that they've lost out
their life savings to a scammer
they shouldn't be embarrassed they
should report this the Andersons say
they'll survive the dollar loss but
others may not we don't want anyone else
to go through this a lot of people since
this has happened to us have gotten
those calls and called us and said I
just got a Social Security call what
should I do and we say hang up that is
the thing to do just hang up but these
scam calls just got even scarier the FBI
put out a warning yesterday saying the
crooks are now spoofing the FBI's phone
number to run scams so when they call it
looks like they're calling from the FBI
then they tell you to buy gift cards
which of course not going to call you
people please don't offer this or all
kinds of wrong I mean they're more than
criminal they're evil very elaborate
first I don't put the Andersons in the
senior category they yes I'm sorry that
she feels so embarrassed because I think
in the moment
you feel scared you don't feel you have
no idea that this is a scam well you
feel embarrassing me in that you've been
taken but at the moment it's fairly
scared so what's the government you
believe that you know these scammers are
pros they are pros very good panicking
people and keeping them on the hook this
went on for nearly a week and you think
that's not gonna happen to me I'm not
gonna be that stupid that's what it
happens so what do you do you reach hang
up stay on the phone don't call your
don't tell your husband don't know do
tell your husband do tell your family do
call the local police oh hang up and
guess what if the government really
needs to talk to you they'll find you a
letter in the mail yeah certified mail
and so you need to call us so they'll
never just call you on the phone that
money's gone it's not coming back it's
not the credit card companies paying it
back and that's the worst thing about it
evil is the right word yeah Anna thank
you very much